(host)
You spot a goblin crouched
like a cat lying in wait.
Just when you least expect it,
you're on his back
and he's taking you
on what will surely
be the wildest
and most terrifying
ride of your life.
The Puca,
a shape-shifting goblin,
terrorizes his victims at
night and plays cruel jokes.
He carries unwilling riders
through brambles
and narrow cliffs
and bestows magical gifts.
Existing somewhere between
boogeyman, scapegoat,
and temperamental fay,
the known trickster
animal spirit
was once dreaded across
Ireland, the Channel Islands,
and England, and has
survived the test of time.
Don't believe me?
Just ask Shakespeare.
[triumphant music]
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka,
and this is "Monstrum."
This monster's influence
is demonstrated by
its hotly-debated etymology.
Puca means goblin
in Old English,
but did that word come
from Scandinavian,
Germanic, or Celtic origins?
Some scholars trace it
back to Icelandic roots.
Others say Norwegian origins
and others, old
Danish or old Swedish.
And there's arguments to be made
for Irish, Welsh, and the
Cornish etymology as well.
That's a lot of
colloquial contention.
The commonality is
that in every language,
the term refers to a negative
spirit, a mischievous monster.
Because the
definition is the same
across so many
different languages,
yet no one clear origin,
to me, that suggests that
this monster was around
for a very long time
before spreading
across Northern Europe.
Like a lot of monsters,
the name might differ
depending on who
is telling the tale
and where they're telling it,
but the basic characteristics
are consistent.
In expressly animal spirit,
they threaten death
but do not kill.
They can bestow kindness,
but generally prefer cruelty,
and they're encountered at night
and during the harvest time
where they frolic
through the hay.
While these
shape-shifting tricksters
can choose to take
on any animal form,
they favor cows, dogs,
donkeys, goats, and horses,
particularly
a small shaggy pony.
In some regions,
they even take on
a diminutive humanoid form.
Their otherworldly nature
is indicated by
completely black coloring
or animal features
like ears, horns, or tail.
The Puca seems to exist
mainly to harass
late-night travelers,
spooking them out of their wits.
Their favorite way to do this,
unexpected rides
through the countryside.
Yep. The monster lies in wait
before popping up, tossing
their victim onto their backs
and bolting across the landscape
with little thought for the
safety or comfort of the rider.
They intentionally run
through thorny bushes,
alongside stone walls, and
on the precipice of cliffs.
These death-defying
rides rarely result
in serious harm to the rider
other than the pure terror.
In some instances,
the monster takes pity
on the naive traveler and
might happily trot them home,
but it is also known
to spoil wild fruits
by urinating or
spitting on them.
In one story, the Puca
gives a magical flute
to a piper that
makes him famous,
but only after playing a few
cruel jokes on him first.
According to legend,
this is the same flute
that makes people
dance until they die,
which seems like a questionable
gift to say the least.
Another interesting trait
of this monster, he talks.
According to the tale,
a farmhand while putting
away the cows after milking
finds himself tossed onto
the back of a young horse.
Throughout the night, the
horse takes him on a rough,
harrowing ride across
the countryside.
The next morning, quite
bruised and worse for wear,
he tells his boss
of the encounter.
The man's advice, "Wear spurs."
When the horse appears again,
the young man asked
to ride on its back,
but the cunning creature seems
to sense something is afoot.
It asks, "Have you
the sharp things on?"
When the farmhand confirms
he does, the horse retreats.
But this is not the last
the farmhand will
see of the monster.
Returning from
a party one night,
the man is startled when a horse
jumps off the path
and knocks him down,
covering the man with his
body in a protective stance.
A bright light blasts down on
the path at that same moment.
The creature rises,
stating that it saved him
from being killed by a spirit.
When the farmhand
asks who saved him,
the horse replies,
"I am the Puca."
There are many variations
of this Puca tale.
The bright light may be
interpreted as a demonic force,
but more commonly,
the spirit or spirits
the story is referring to are
the good people, the fay folk.
In every version of this
legend, and there are a lot,
the Puca never calls
the spurs by their name.
The monster refers to them
only as sharp things
regardless of if the story
is told in English,
Gaelic, or any other language.
The Puca's aversion
is important enough
that even in one story
where the creature
attacks a fisherman,
the man is able
to defeat the Puca
by attaching a row of hooks
on his heels like spurs.
Spurs are used to
control horses,
so why would
a supernatural being
have such a hatred
of the sharp things?
Well, spurs are traditionally
made from steel or iron.
Those of you with a little
knowledge of the fay
might recognize the folkloric
significance of iron,
which is said to
deter or injure them.
The Puca's reluctance to
even speak the word for spur
might be a nod to this tradition
and could hint at the
monster's own lineage.
The Puca's connection to the
good people of Celtic lore
reiterates that its
origins are quite old.
While monks who came to Ireland
started writing down
these traditions
around the 17th century, be
assured that oral storytelling
was an integral part of Irish
culture long before that.
And remember, these stories
are not memorized scripts,
but ever-changing performances
between Seanachie,
traditional Gaelic
storytellers, and audience.
As Christianity's
influence grew in Ireland,
the animal trickster spirit is
replaced by a guardian angel
or other angelic being in
the farmhand narrative,
turning the story into one
about the divine
influence of God
rather than Puca intervention.
The Puca remains
relatively the same
in appearance and
action across Ireland
and other parts of Europe,
even as Christianity
becomes more prevalent.
Sometimes characteristics
have important enough
moral, cultural,
and social meaning
that they need to
remain the same.
Take the monster's
connection to The Wild Hunt,
an archaic folklore
trope involving a divine
or semi-divine figure
leading a band of supernatural
entities and/or the dead
on a nighttime horseback hunt
that causes general havoc
and fear amongst humans.
The Wild Hunt is linked back
to ancient cults of
fertility, death,
ancestor worship, and magic.
The Puca who forcefully takes
humans on death-defying rides
could fit right
into this narrative,
which would make
it very old indeed.
The places the Puca appear
often bear that name
and have ecological and
economic importance or value.
There are marshes, rocks,
waterfalls, caverns, wells,
and other spots
across Northern Europe
with some variation of Puca
as part of their place names,
designating biological habitats
and resources that should
be left undisturbed by man.
Places like Pollaphuca
and Puckstown.
In Fayapooka in
Kerry County Ireland,
it was said a Puca resided
undisturbed by mortals
in a particular marsh
for over a century
until a young man named
Tim Dorney inherited the land
and decided to cut the marsh up
with drains and dishes.
Driven from its home,
the Puca becomes enraged and
begins harassing Tim's family.
One night while surveying
his land for stray cattle,
Tim finds himself on
the back of a monster
who is galloping
at a furious pace.
Held on by an invisible force,
Tim is unable to dismount.
The monster scrapes him against
stone walls, through bushes,
and eventually almost
throws him off a cliff,
deciding at the last second
to spare him,
satisfied by
the man's immense fear.
Tim is enraged by this encounter
and swears revenge
on the creature.
He takes to wearing
long-neck spurs
and carries a weighted
whip with an iron grip.
When the Puca takes him
for another wild ride,
it suffers great pain
from these devices.
These sharp things are enough
to deter the Puca for a time.
Years pass until one night
when Tim is returning home
from a late-night card game,
he comes across a small horse
tied up next to
the bank of a river.
The docile horse
wears a straw saddle
with a white thorn
branch tucked inside.
The white thorn plant
is said to be unlucky
and can attract fairies.
Tim recognizes this warning,
salutes the Puca,
and continues to walk home.
But this won't be the end of
his run-ins with the monster.
The Puca avenges his injuries
by driving Tim's
horses off a cliff,
horses that were carrying
butter meant to pay Tim's rent.
And without the butter,
Tim loses the farm and the
Puca reigns victorious,
having rid himself of
an inhospitable family.
This story is a cautionary
tale against disrupting nature,
but it also promotes
something else,
a reverence for folklore.
Tim can keep his life and
his land for a longer period
only because he recognizes
the white thorn branch
as a warning,
promoting the idea that
these so-called superstitions
and legends protect
those who know them.
Any crops left after sowen
are considered
tainted by the Puca
and in some places the monsters
left offerings as placation.
This might be a way to
encourage resource management
and ensure the harvest
is fully collected
before it can spoil.
Even when ridiculed,
the legends of the Puca
are acknowledged as part of
national and cultural histories
and over time, the
monster's integration
into literature
and popular fiction
solidifies its place
as a common social convention.
Puck, the mischievous
shape-shifting narrator
of Shakespeare's
"A Midsummer Night's Dream"
clearly borrows its name and
nature from the Puca tradition.
Like the folkloric figure,
Shakespeare's Puck,
the merry wanderer of the night
is unbothered by the effects
of his actions on humans,
which include misleading
night wanderers,
crafting potions,
pouring drinks on people,
and turning human heads
into donkey heads.
But don't think the Puca's
influence ended centuries ago.
It appears in the
guise of a black goat
with long horns standing
on its hind legs
in Thomas Crofton Croker's
"Fairy Legends and Traditions"
in the 19th century,
a text whose great popularity
undoubtedly introduced many
more people to the creature.
In 20th century
plays and movies,
the Puca's legend
influences characters,
sometimes in a comedic way.
In a 1950 film, "Harvey",
a giant rabbit appears only
to main character Elwood.
Harvey is mischievous,
pulling pranks and
causing confusion.
About a decade later,
a more direct association
turns up in the movie "Darby
O'Gill and the Little People".
An Irish king owns
a mischievous horse
that can change color,
disappear, and is named Pooka.
In the 21st century,
we get more modern
and metaphorical versions
of the Puca.
Fans and some
scholars, I'm both,
of the 2001
cult classic "Donnie Darko"
believe a Puca is at its core,
one who leans into
the more malevolent
mischievousness of the monster.
Then there's Pooka
from the "Into the Dark"
horror anthology.
This might be the most unusual
and unnerving
interpretation of the Puca,
a toy that records
what its owner says
in either naughty or nice mode.
When an actor's hired
to wear the promotional
first suit version
of the character,
an interesting take
on the monster's
shape-shifting abilities,
it quickly consumes him,
taking over his personality.
Stories of the Puca
continue to circulate today,
both in oral tradition
and popular culture.
Whatever form the
shape-shifting creature takes,
it always manages to disrupt
the lives of those around it,
for better or worse.
The very malleability of the
Puca's form helps it endure.
Who knows what shape
it will take next?
Am I on the right mark?
(Director)
Yep, you're perfect.
-[claps]
-Sorry.
It was literally right
in front of my face.
Okay.
Nature indicated with
completely black coloring
or animal features like
ears, horns, or a tail.
[pair laughing]